this morning search crews in New Zealand
will try to recover eight people
presumed killed in Monday's volcanic
eruption eight others already are
confirmed dead more than 20 people
remain hospitalized with severe burns
nine Americans are among the wounded
ramie innocencio is info Kotani New
Zealand and got a closer view of the
volcano
good morning four days after the
eruption this recovery option gives
family members a glimmer of hope and at
the same time officials hope that the
volcano will quiet down just enough to
let them recover the bodies of those who
didn't make it
clearing New Zealand's eastern coast our
helicopter zoomed 25 miles closer to the
steaming plume of White Mountain New
Zealand's most active volcano
dramatically erupted Monday 47 people
were caught in a fight for their lives a
mix of travelers from the US Europe and
Asia Pacific the latest confirmed
fatalities two brothers 16 year old
Barron Hollander and 13 year old Matthew
both born in Chicago
their parents Martin and Barbara are
among the missing Matthew and Lauren URI
newlyweds from Virginia were severely
burned and are now being treated we're
now 2,200 feet above the volcano
it looks pretty peaceful now but that
bloom you can see indicates that this is
still a very seismically active volcano
and that means that people can't get on
there to recover the eight victims who
are still on the island
New Zealand der Heyden Marshall Inman
was the first confirmed death with his
remains still on the volcano his brother
Mark is frustrated rid type bracha c
leadership has filed helicopter pilot
Jason Hill flew five wounded people off
the volcano Monday and you do it again
hundred hundred and teams see New
Zealand Geoscience expert Nico Fournier
this is one of the most seismically
active regions of the world how did we
not know that this was going to happen
it's simply the nature of the beast
so some volcanoes are easier to forecast
than others and now New Zealand waits
for sunrise to see if it is indeed safe
enough to launch that recovery operation
to retrieve the body
of those eight victims but police say
there is no zero risk option case in
point
New Zealand's Geoscience agency says
there's a 50 to 60 percent chance of a
second eruption in the next 24 hours
Tony maybe you know sensor you for us in
New Zealand Randi thank you very much